It's very rarely used but the word “nibble”
means half of a computer byte.
In Bolivia, llama droppings are used to purify
water.
To kit yourself out as a real-life Batman
would cost about $300 million.
18% of the average American's income is spent
on transportation.
Chemicals caused female munitions workers
in the First World War to give birth to yellow
babies.
There are more stars in the universe than
words have been spoken by all of the humans
who have ever lived.
A day on the International Space Station is
one and a half hours long.
Only six out of 22 crocodile species present
any danger to humans.
Until 1900, visitors to Stonehenge were given
chisels so they could chip off a souvenir.
There are more species of plant on Cape Town's
Table Mountain than in the whole of the UK.
The Queen's staff get to choose their own
Christmas presents, which must be worth between
£20 and £25.
Picasso painted using ordinary house paint.
The United States has never lost a war in
which donkeys were used.
It is cheaper to send Scottish cod to China
to be filleted and sent back again than to
fillet the fish in Scotland.
Heineken beer is designed to foam for precisely
five minutes.
In 19th century Britain, attempting to commit
suicide was against the law and was punishable
by death.